[inaudible]
I want to shift to the book or you want
to keep going? No, no, no. Please, please.
I would much rather talk about this book.
All right. So it's called blueprint,
the evolutionary origins
of a good society. So let's
start with the tag there.
So we actually live in a good society.
I can't believe it.
I thought we live in the worst society
ever and I thought capitalism is evil and
the patriarchy and so many terrible
things and we've done horrible things.
But you say this is
good. Yeah, I'm appalled.
Can you please explain this
matter statement? Yes. Okay.
So I think there has been a long tradition
in the sciences and in the public
domain as well of um,
focusing on the bad side of human nature,
on our propensity for tribalism or
selfishness or violence or hatred.
But equally we are natural selection of
our evolution has equipped us and shaped
us for love and friendship and cooperation
and teaching and all these other
wonderful qualities.
And in fact,
I would argue that these good qualities
and their benefits must necessarily have
outweighed the bad qualities and their
costs. Because if I came near you,
I'm now speaking of
over evolutionary time,
over tens or hundreds
of thousands of years.
If I came near you and you killed me or
filled me with lies or otherwise injured
me, I would be better off
living separately. So, so the,
so the fact that we live
socially suggest that on balance,
the benefits of a connected
life must outweigh the costs.
So the books, the book,
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
push back at these claims that we are,
that humans are inexorably evil.
And these arguments I should make,
I should say, are
supplementary to the, uh,
the body of ideas that Steven pinker
and others had been advancing about the
sweep of history. So where Stephen
is interested in historical forces,
I'm interested in the books
over there. So yeah. And Amy's,
I see in a bunch of other younger Steven
and give me all my friends Neil Neil
crew by data. So you want
to be a man? Yes, please.
Put me over there with those guys. Yes,
exactly. You're like some of those guys.
Yes. And Schirmer's book. I can see.
Yeah. These are great. Um, okay. So, uh,
uh, yeah, the moral arc
that you know. Okay, great.
So I'll make sure you have a copy.
Okay. But anyway, um, so, so, um,
so, uh, uh, so Steven is
arguing that, uh, you know,
basically since the enlightenment
philosophical principles in the scientific
discoveries,
discoveries of the enlightenment,
the world has been getting better and
he's unquestionably bright. We are safer,
less violent, healthier, live, longer,
wealthier, better off in every,
every possible dimension. And that is
largely a product of historical forces.
But what I'm arguing and
technological forces,
but when I'm arguing is that we don't
just have to look to our history to find
this goodness.
We can look to our pre history.
And actually over tens of thousands
of years we've been shaped to be good.
We have been shaped to be able to live
together in productive ways, in, in, in,
in good ways, actually in morally
good ways. I even argue so,
so the both work synergistically,
these two forces and in,
and in fact I would even argue that
these historical and technological forces
are actually just a thin veneer on
top of much more powerful forces.
So is there a bizarre evolutionary force
that that inclines us to focus on the
negative on? No, that's a good question.
I suspect if I had to, I get one per show.
No, no, no, no, no. Um, I would say right,
cause if you ask if you a
person are things good or bad,
people generally tend to bed. We watch
local news. That is all terrible news.
We're conditioned sort of. So there must
be something that's leading to that. Yes.
I think that, I think, I
know this has been studied,
I'm trying to quickly call
the literature to my mind. Um,
if I had to speculate on what the
conclusions of that literature would be,
it would be that there's more advantage
to paying attention to bad news and good
news that the fitness advantage
of survival advantage,
the advantage to your wellbeing from,
um,
noting a fire in your vicinity
or a Predator or a killer,
uh, is more advantageous
to you than, than, uh,
than noted the noting that on average
the presence of water or a food or a
kindly person.
So I think,
I think that that's probably why
we're hardwired to be pessimistic,
but actually we're not,
let me be clear. So,
so we have both pessimistic and
optimistic, uh, inclinations people,
and of course there's Inter individual
variation. People vary in this,
these personality traits.
But I think overall we are
definitely inclined to the good.
So when you described yourself
as an optimist before,
if you had to try to parse that out
between what you think human nature is
versus upbringing and everything else,
could you give it some percentages?
I mean where your parents,
optimists so that then push a well as
ideas to you or I think it's important not
to conflate personality traits,
uh,
which I am a optimist I think in
person by personality with um,
sort of,
um,
how to put this exactly the kind
of characteristics of our species.
So I think we, for example,
we are cooperative species.
We cooperate with strangers,
which is very unusual.
Other animals will cooperate with kin,
but we also cooperate with non-kin
rare in the animal kingdom.
So I don't know how you
would describe that.
I wouldn't call that optimism exactly.
I would call that something
good cooperativity.
That's a characteristic of our species.
And then above and beyond that
we also have personalities.
Some of us are optimistic, some of us
are not. But all of us, for example,
love our mates. So here's an
interesting idea why, why do we do that?
Other animals to have sex with each other.
We're not the only animals that do this,
but we also love each other.
We formed sentimental attachments to
the people we are having sex with.
We are also tend to be monogamous.
And that we can be by monogamous,
I don't mean social monogamy
or even heterosexual monogamy.
I mean we form a longterm attachment
to the person we're having sex with.
Whether it's polygynous, polyandrous,
straight or gay, doesn't matter.
We love the person we're with. Why?
Why do we evolve this capacity? Well,
I talk a little bit about that. Why
would do that? And it's universal.
Everywhere in the world you go,
no matter what the marital system,
people love their partners instantly.
Plus we get too proud of ourselves. Birds.
90% of bird species are also monogamous.
But anyway,
so the point is is that there are all
these qualities we have or we befriend
each other. Why do we do that? We, we
don't just reproduce with each other.
We form longterm non reproductive unions
with other members of our species.
Namely, we have friends. This is very
rare in the animal kingdom. We do it.
Certain primates do it, whales, orcas
and dolphins do it. And elephants do it.
Why? Well, there's a reason we do it and
it's a wonderful quality of our species.
So do you think societies
should be organized to help
these institutions? I mean,
this is where I could throw out Jordan
Peterson's enforced monogamy and you know,
people had a field day with that and all
he really was saying was that societies
should kind of look at marriages,
it Justin thing because
it's a foundational thing
that will help you build a
family,
has helped you build it for full of life.
Do you agree that that's part of what
would lead to a good society or which
should be instilled? Well, I say
I talk about that in the book. Uh,
when I talk about is that we should be
very wary of efforts to engineer society
in opposition to our evolved proclivities.
So societies that try for example,
to prevent loving attachments.
I talk about communes,
for example,
communes have a problem because in a
commune they want you to feel loyalty to
the group,
to the commune.
So therefore feeling of love
for your partner is a threat.
So many communes have gone
two opposite extremes,
both of which are attempting
to solve the same problem.
So on the one hand you have the shakers
who say no sex, no loving attachment.
On the other hand,
you have comments that say polyamory,
everyone loves everybody or
can have sex with everyone.
Both of those are attempting to sever an
individualistic connection between two
people,
which therefore you,
and the same thing happens in eastern
Germany where they tried to several
connections with friends,
right? You don't,
you who my friends could be spying on
me or ratting out to the Stazi. It's,
it's sitting there for a second
cause it's a fascinating idea.
The same force at work. Whether you say
to people don't have any release. Yes,
he's actually the same course as have
relations with everybody. I mean that's,
that's not something that the
average person is thinking about.
But if you're just having relations
with everybody, yes, you're actually,
I don't think there's want special
nobody. That's right. So they're both,
both of those extreme strategies
are tackling the same problem,
which is the threat to the collectivity
of individual relationships,
whether it's with your partner,
your sexual partner,
or as I was about to say
with your friends or others.
So collectivist societies will often,
every week everyone call you comrade.
So everyone is your friend.
Same as having polyamory, right?
It's like the polyamorous equivalent
to everyone dresses the same.
We all call each other friend. No
individual identity. It's a kind of,
it's a kind of science fiction,
dystopia.
So the argument I make is that we should
be very wary of efforts to engineer
society in opposition to our interests.
There are bound to fail is my argument.
Now there are brief moments of time and
certain cultures where you can apply a
tremendous cultural force and suppress
some of these innate tendencies.
So for example,
I talk about the not,
so if you look at societies around
the world that the, the, the,
the expression of love for your is seen
universally except perhaps with one
exception,
which is the not people in the Himalayas
who've organized society around a brief
sexual encounters.
You're not supposed to love your partner.
And so this is a matrilineal society.
The women stay at home.
The men will go out at night basically
cruising for dates. So there'll be like,
and it's not uncommon for every woman
to have had sex with every man in the
village. And, uh, the, the
men will be knocking on the
door, take me tonight, take me,
and she'll pick this guy tonight
and they'll have a brief fling.
Maybe he can come back.
And at any moment,
either of them can break off the
relationship, but even in it.
And so there's a whole complex cultural
edifice. Marco Polo describes this.
When he gets to China,
the Chinese government thought
it was sapping productivity,
that everyone was having sex all the
time. They were, they were saying,
and we need to stop this. They tried to
stamp it out, but it still has existed.
This, this culture, this, this cultural
set of rules. But even in this society,
there are people who want the
forbidden fruit of having a,
a committed relationship and who flee
for because they want to be with each
other,
forsaking all others.
So even the society cannot fully
suppressed this desire for love.
And I look also at friendship and
show that there are some societies,
very few which seem to have no,
um,
experience of this notion of friendship.
But those societies are extremely rare
and also have certain idiosyncrasies.
So the simple way of saying that there's
basically an evolutionary force that no
matter how far you go to one extreme,
it has to sort of push you. Yes.
Or that it's extremely difficult
to entirely suppressed.
You can through force of arms, you know,
you can slaughter populations, you can,
you can, you know, you can, uh, you
can um, have very elaborate, uh,
sort of autocratic governments.
You can have procedures or other highly
evolved stylized cultures that have
cotton to this.
For example,
there's a play is universal and children
and there's one society that banning
people who really think play is awful
and really try to suppress the innate
tendency of children to play.
So there's very little play among
children in that society, but it's,
these societies are rare and they require
very large cultural forces to suppress
these innate tendencies.
You know,
I was thinking as we've
been talking about this,
that there's something
also sort of related to our
political situation right now
about this, that it seems like we're
sort of going off the deep end.
I would say the argue more on
the left at the moment. Um,
but I guess if I'm an optimist here and
I described myself as a world weary opt
that you're saying at some point and
whether Jonathan Haidt says it's two years
down the road or whenever it is,
but at some point that will eventually
have to rebound. Right? Cause sure.
What is it? If it doesn't rebound
then, then that's just, no,
I don't think Jordan Peterson would say
is just chaos. Right? Yeah. I think,
I think, I mean, I, I can't,
I think we're in for another,
I think there'll be about five or 10
years our society is going to go through a
long period of, of, of acrimony. No,
I have to say I'm not, you know, um, sort
of don't have a wig ish view of history.
Like, oh, in the olden days, you know,
uh, everything was great. I mean,
let's not forget we had, we had
colonialism, we had slavery, we had a,
we had die anti immigrant sentiment
forever and are because even vote,
I mean women couldn't vote. Exactly. Do
you have gay rights? You know. Uh, so,
so there's always been this,
uh,
this incredible disconnect between our
wonderful principles in our society.
All men are created equal.
You know,
the bill of rights can bring tears
to your eyes if you read it, but a,
and the fact that we didn't always,
but we are, I think getting better.
This is the progressive in
me, you know, the society,
we're getting better and better.
We are expanding the franchise
to more and more people.
We are opening up our democracy.
We are, we are extending rights,
we are extending liberties. Um,
now of course the libertarian,
we'll say the government doesn't grant
liberty. We are protecting liberties are,
you know, we are trying to stay out, but
it took me right out of my head. Exactly.
And I agree with that actually.
I don't think the liberties for the
governments to grant, but anyway, so,
uh, but I think our society's is
getting better in these regards. Um,
I don't think you can, you could
say otherwise. So I think that we,
we will get there.
It just is gonna take some time.
So how do you navigate through
a messy time like this?
If you're someone that's just kind of
awake to these ideas and you want to be
able to express your individuality,
but there is a mob or a morphous
machine that is silencing things,
or as you just said before,
that you don't want a society that's going
to push down things that were sort of
always accepted for a long time.
I'm slightly paraphrasing, but,
so right now it's like
if you call a man a man,
they'll tell you you're a transfer.
These, these basic things that seem,
now we hear about them constantly as if,
as if this is just the most
important thing happening. And No,
I think there are other, this is
the other thing. I think that,
I think there are certain segments of
Twitter and certain segments of our
society that have made these particular
topics and others a very central,
and everyone, you know,
the people who want to,
who are concerned about climate
change or people who come as I am,
there are people who are concerned about
the private practice prison industry as
I am. These are two hot
topics at Harvard right now.
So there was a heckler situation
where the president of Harvard was,
was not allowed to speak about,
he was at an educational conference
and these groups that were opposed to
private ownership of prisons, which I am
and, uh, concern about climate change,
which I also am, they shut the president
down, which is ridiculous, you know?
And why did they shut him down?
Cause he thought he wasn't taking,
paying enough attention to their concerns.
So you have this kind of
rule by minorities, right?
Where am I in a vocal minority can
hijack the conversation about whatever
particular topic they have.
So everyone's entitled to
have their topics of interest.
But that doesn't mean you have
to go along with it right?
You can have your own ideas about the
topic or you can switch conversation.
Like I'm not interested in
talking about trans rights today.
Today I'd like to talk about,
uh,
how motor vehicle accidents are the one
of the leading killers or the opioid
crisis is another important dilemma.
Or the guns. You know, we, we, we have,
we have more people are killed by guns
in our society per capita than any
society in the world almost.
It's craziness. So, um,
so all of these are different
people have different, anyway,
the point I'm making is that if you
wish to engage in a conversation with
someone about a topic
they feel strongly about,
I think it's incumbent on you to
listen to their arguments, think,
and then respond.
So do you think there's an evolutionary
reason that people either basically
become sort of government
people or freedom people?
So the way you were laying out that
argument, it's not going to go,
it's like you were telling me your
progressive, uh, sort of prayed,
which I have to do all the time.
But then you basically said, yeah,
but all these things can be accomplished
by libertarianism if you don't believe
that it's the government's
job to give these things.
So that basically it sort of shows why
the progressive's are the ones screaming
on campus all the time and in and in
larger society because they think the
system can be perfected to
get it however they want it.
Where the Libertarians, I think
just say I'm very wearable. Yeah,
I don't think the system can be perfect.
So let's just keep it out of our lives.
I mean, I think, you know, which,
which idea I'm more sympathetic to,
but do you think there's a reason that,
well, I heard that,
yes. Okay. So there are,
there are a set of ideas about where do,
where do so, so the content of
political beliefs, like whether,
for example, you believe in, um,
whatever it is, pick, I know any,
the, the, the belief you have about a
particular topic because of course not
evolutionarily shaped,
but there is a kind of evolutionary
shaping to whether or not you are more
conservative or liberal. Let's it,
that's what I'm trying to get. Yeah.
So some people are more rule abiding and
there's an, there's a good, for example,
children that learn children that listen
to their parents might be more likely
to survive. So listening to your parents
is actually a good survival strategy.
On the other hand,
too much obedience is also bad.
You can be led like a lemming off a cliff.
So occasionally you need to not
listen to what everyone else is doing.
So both are advantageous and we're,
we're equipped with both abilities and
there's variation across people and it's
a complicated topic.
So nobody thinks there's like a genetic
background to being a Democrat or a
Republican.
But there is evidence that there is a
kind of genetic predisposition to certain
political polls.
But what I would say though is
that we live in a plural democracy.
So you're going to have to
compromise, you know, uh,
if you're libertarian who
thinks x, Y, and Z and you're,
you're going to be in a society with
other people who think different things.
We have decided to come together as a
people and vote to resolve our disputes.
And t by the way,
not to vote,
but to educate ourselves and to teach
each other stuff. Right. To communicate.
Right. The founders recognize
that in order for us to
get to the wisest decision,
we have to have free and
open conversation. Right.
Well, I think that's why,
which I support. I do hear
of. Cool. Of course you do.
But that's why so many people are so
concerned about this at the college layer.
You know, I'll hear some of
our critics will say, oh,
they're just obsessed with
what's happening on colleges
and they're handing over
all this power to the, to the
mob oncologists. But then,
but then every day we
see it then leak out.
And also these people will
be the leaders of tomorrow.
That's why I don't think it's,
I don't think it's overestimating.
And even if it is a small minority,
which we agree,
the amount of power they can extend,
they definitely used to be way
disproportionate to the numbers for sure.
I would agree with that.
Uh,
I would agree that the vast majority of
students on any college campus just want
to get a good education. And, um,
and many of them have other political
concerns other than some of the ones that
are getting a lot of attention. So, um,
you know, even for example, even with the,
you know, so you know, people are
concerned about the opiod crisis.
They're concerned about gun violence,
are concerned about police brutality.
They're concerned about
the climate change,
are concerned about all of these issues,
which I think warrant concerned.
We can perfect our society, we can be
better than we are. And I generally,
we can perfect it. I, I do better than
we are. We think we can perfect it. No,
I don't think we can
have a perfect society,
but I think we can make it better than it
is. So by perfect, I mean improve. Okay.
Um, so I think we can make
our society better and better.
I don't think we're done
yet. I think there's still
deficits in our, for example,
our spending is crazy. I'm going to
think we do better fiscal fiscally. Um,
you know, I think we have, we have
a carceral state. We have, I think,
I think this number's right,
that upper on a per capita basis.
We have as many people in prisons as
Stalinist Russia. I mean it's insane.
You know,
we have millions of Americans are in
prison and it's way out of proportion to
other countries. Um, you know, there
are lots of things about our society.
We have very high,
we have century long heights of
income inequality in our society.
There's a big debate about whether that
is an unavoidable side effect of growth.
You know,
everyone is better off.
So what do we care if the
income is unequally distributed?
But I think I tend to be agree with the
critics that are concerned that this
level of inequalities not sustainable
to have a common wheel to like have a
sense that everyone is
a part of the society.
We've had no income growth in the middle.
Uh,
like the meeting American has seen in a
generation and see no growth in wages.
Right? So the bottom actually has raised
and we've watched the top go bananas,
but the middle of it, no,
the bottom hasn't even gone
up that much either. Well,
let me, let me put it this way, they have
absolutely not been living standards,
right? So like a poor American today is
vastly better off than a poor American a
generation ago. But in terms of wage
growth, there's been very little growth.
My understanding of statistics and most
of the accumulation of wealth in the
last generation has gone to the top,
top 1% top 0.1% anyway,
there's a debate about why that happened.
The technological advance.
Do we have the same thing during
the industrial revolution?
These are important deep ideas,
which as a society,
we should be debating and discussing
what's the best for our society anyway.
Third, these are all bunch more
important topics in my view,
and have much more bearing on the
wellbeing of our society than a lot of the
other crap that gets so much attention.
So what's the evolutionary
reason for that? I mean,
your previous book was about social media,
right?
And so there's gotta be some link there.
I mean,
and that's where he gets back to what I
was saying about depressing local news.
I don't know. I mean, I'm trying to talk
about things that I think are important.
Um, you know, I, I, um, I'm
doing my part as best I can,
who's done a society in a more quote
unquote good way than we have right now.
So, uh, so the book, so I don't, I don't,
I'm not, it's not a work of history,
so I'm not, I'm not, I don't
primarily talk about, um,
like the last 200 or even 2000 years
of human evolution or experience.
I'm much more interested in the long
arc of our history. And if you look at,
um, forge your societies around
the world as I do, and you,
and you look at their qualities,
you will see that again and again.
These societies have these
desirable properties. They,
there's variation of course,
and how cooperative they are.
And there's variation in marital systems
and there's variation in sustenance
systems. There's a lot of variation.
But also there's a lot of commonality.
And those common features I argue are
universal. See, here's the other argument.
So the argument is that there are these
universal qualities that are shared
across all societies.
They are shaped by our evolution.
They're not just a product
of historical forces.
Can you just list out a couple
of them again just so, so love.
So love a friendship. Uh, cooperation.
We're cooperative species.
You will be kind to a stranger
on the first, you know, uh,
teaching the fact that we
teach each other stuff,
which actually is the ultimate source
of all our wealth and wellbeing.
The fact that we can accumulate knowledge
and distributed across time and place.
So I can tell people far away something
and when I'm born I benefit from all the
other knowledge that has
been produced for the men.
Did hundreds of thousands
of years before me.
Is this punishing and I would
again argue this is why,
what's happening on college. Yes. I
would argue, I would agree with that.
There's a connection there.
Like our capacity to teach and to
create environments in which we foster
teaching and learning are crucial anyway.
Also mild hierarchy.
We are a species that we cannot
survive with no hierarchy.
We need some leaders and I discussed
that but we also don't like too much
hierarchy.
So when you get too autocratic of power,
the little guys down below band
together and basically kill.
So Richard Wrangham has been making this
argument that we self domesticated as a
species that over millennia bands of
weaker members would say, you know,
that guy's too powerful and he's getting
all the dates and this we're going to
kill him. And basically they did. So
we got more peaceful as time went by.
Is One of the ideas mild
hierarchy in group bias.
So some tribalism is
unavoidable in human beings. Um,
this capacity for identity that
we discussed at the beginning.
These are all qualities. So identity,
love, friendship, social networks,
mild hierarchy, Ingroup bias,
teaching and social learning.
These are seen everywhere and they lie.
And I believe that the core of a
good society and, and institutions,
uh, uh, try to suppress those
at their own peril. Yeah.
How can you be sort of,
have a healthy dose of in group preference
without starting to fall into the
trap of identity politics. So for example,
you're a Greek guys who grew up in a,
in a Greek family. Did I love Greek? My
best child friends growing up is great.
We're still great friends.
Um,
I love Greek culture and the way it
opened the Greek and the interest in
intellectual wisdom and I love fed
cheese and all of those things.
SPANAKOPITA dialogue. Yes. Great. So,
and you can open a Greek
restaurant as far as I'm concerned,
I wouldn't object to that.
That'd be [inaudible] that port,
that poor girl. It's insane. Yeah.
It's total Chinese restaurants without
being Chinese. And then they're coming in,
not just that there was the,
there's the person in, in,
in Oregon that had a Mexican restaurant.
Yes.
There's so many examples
of this is unbelievable. So
how can you say love uncle?
I just told you all the reasons. I
love your history, but let's pretend,
let's say it's roughly the same
feelings about your own culture.
How can you embrace all of those
things without falling into the trap of
identity politics?
Because I think that's where a lot
of people are at these days. Okay.
So I have a couple of ideas and responses
that the first thing I would say is,
is that that this is one
of the both the most,
it's still not totally clear how
we evolve to have this capacity.
It's felt that this ingroup bias,
this I,
this tribalism that we have was
crucial to our ability to cooperate.
That the ability to draw a distinction
between us and them, the challenge,
the problem that, that this ability
that we evolved. So, so there's,
whether we cooperate with each other
and whether we are xenophobic or
tribalistic or draw distinctions
between us and them. And this property,
this tribalism property is a property
that reduces the scale of interaction.
So instead of you having to
cooperate with everybody,
you only cooperate with your guys.
And this is innate in human beings.
And it is felt that this ability to
draw distinction between us and then was
crucial in the emergence of
the variability to cooperate
with other people. Okay.
So they're tied, they're connected
to each other. What's depressing is,
is it necessary to hate the other group?
Why can't you just love your own group?
Right?
So why could you be indifferent to the
other group or even admire it and they've
got to them,
they're not us.
We like them or we are in different to
them, right? Why do we have to kill them,
right? Like why, you know, where does
the killing part come from? Right?
And this is complicated.
We don't exactly know like where
the hostility comes in weather,
but we tend to see this hostility.
So for example,
there are famous experiments that
have been done with little toddlers.
You can randomly assign toddlers
to different tee shirts.
You can test at the toddlers
understand that this was random,
that there was no merit to whether they
got the yellow t shirt or the green t
shirt. And yet as soon as you give
them the t shirts, the yellow t shirt,
kids say those green t shirt children,
they shouldn't have toys.
They're bad children. They don't
deserve anything. It's insane.
Like you can see this is called
the minimal group experiments.
So the most trivial of interventions
you can elicit in us this, this, this,
dislike of the other.
However,
this is not the only tool that
evolution has given us to live together,
this disability to draw the
boundary between us and them. Uh,
there are a couple of other tools,
and before I tell you what
those two other tools are,
let me just say one other thing.
So if you think of our society is,
here's our whole society and
here's our groups in the middle,
and here are individuals at the bottom.
If you're struggling with
the problem of tribalism,
there are basically two ways you can go.
You can go up a level and broaden
the boundary. And you can say,
for example, we are all
Americans, right? You can say,
because we all have the
capacity to draw the boundary,
we are evolved to have that capacity.
Now you're just say,
actually these little group boundaries
that we were paying attention to,
they're not,
they're not relevant and basically take
all the ethnic divisions or other than
the religious or immigrant or whatever
it is, and we're all American.
We're all Americans. Other group
at yes. At a higher level. Exactly.
So you move up a level and [inaudible]
face tribalism by appeal to larger groups.
This has been part of our history
since the beginning to talk.
They'll talks about this where
nature of joiners, you know,
anyone can be an American, that that
itself is part of the American project.
It's astonishing.
The belief which I share that anyone can
be an American is a statement that the
groups don't matter.
Anyone can be an American and you just
have to buy our liberal principles and
then you could be an American. Okay. Even
though there's a debate about that. Yes,
yes.
But there's also an interesting parable
to Trump here because at some level it's
like he's talking about
a miracle all the time.
So that is the higher
group for all of this.
And yet I suspect your feelings on
what he's doing. Some other things,
probably not. No, but I would be
like, anyone can be an American.
If you come to our country and you work
and are productive and and obey our laws
and our constitution, you're an
American as far as I'm concerned.
It didn't matter whether you
came from Mexico or you know,
one of the four Mexican countries
as he's, you know, anyway, okay,
so a whole other video, whole other
show. Okay. So, so, okay, so, so,
but another solution,
okay to the group is of the
tribalism is trickle down a level.
Remember we talked
earlier about individuals.
So now you can say instead of looking
at people as which groups are they a
member of,
you look at them as individual people.
And this too has been
a part of our history.
So Martin Luther King's
famous sentiment, I, you know,
I look forward to a society in which
people are judged by the content of their
character rather than the color of their
skin isn't appeal to our individuality.
Seeing groups don't matter.
Individuals matter. So,
so if we're struggling with tribalism
and go up or we can go down both help,
however lateral to that point,
there's another set of ideas,
which is tribalism is not even the only
tool we have in order to reduce the
sense of scale and to cooperate.
So natural selection is also
equipped us with friendship.
Friendship.
The real,
one of the reasons it is felt we evolved
the capacity for friendship is again,
to reduce the sense of scale.
So instead of now being in a big group,
everyone has to cooperate with everyone.
Each of us has a subset of people who
are our friends that we cooperate with.
So it's similar to tribalism but different
because now instead of defining it by
group, membership is defined by each
person has their particular friends.
So this is another tool that we innately
have that we can use to sustain our
cooperative instincts and
push aside the tribalism.
So how much do you think on a day, day,
day, and a day to day basis? Are We, uh,
normally I get the water for people.
You have to be so wrapped up there that
I forgot, uh, on a day to day basis,
how much movement do we as individuals
have to sort of either go around,
let's say go around are a evolutionary
behavior? Well, I don't think, okay.
So I think I do believe in free
will. I mean, I think you have, um,
some capacity to self mastery and make
your own decisions in life and your own,
you know,
um,
but you're also born with certain innate
qualities and you're also born a human
being, which is you're part
of a particular species
that has a particular set of
characteristics. Um, so I,
I think that as individuals, you know,
we, we have some control over how we act.
I don't think our individual actions will
individually change the whole society.
But I think if each of us is
attempting to do the right thing,
I think ultimately that
makes things better. Look,
there's a lot of famous ideas.
Uh, so a Viktor Frankl who was
in the concentration camps, his,
his wife was killed.
He survives the Nazi
concentration camps and he goes,
and he writes a famous book called Man's
search for meaning after he's liberated
it right to 10 days after his liberation.
And he talks about how he came to the
recognition that even in this camp,
in the most vile possible circumstance
where his life was threatened every day,
where people were dying all the time, he
was starving to death. He had no shoes.
It was in the winter. I mean,
it was a slave. Even there,
he recognized that he was the master
of his own internal state. You know,
that how he saw the world was
something that was in his own control.
So he was able to find a sense of
self discipline and mastery even in an
environment in which the structures
around him were engineered to crush him,
um, to kill him. So, so
I think that there are,
and there are many examples of this,
I mean,
another one of my favorite examples is
Buddhist monks that were studied at MIT
years ago. I think I'm going to get
the facts of this work correct. So, so,
so they were very interested in how
meditation changes the structure of your
brain and how are these monks so able to
be so peaceful in these very stressful
circumstances.
And they scan them,
they put them in the MRI scanner and
they looked at different parts of their
brain in which parts were enhanced or
diminished compared to other more ordinary
mortals. And uh, and then,
and they saw the different parts of the
brain and Buddhist monks were different
than the rest of us.
But what interested me was not even the
neuroanatomical discoveries that were in
that paper,
but it was the interviews with the monks.
And so at the monks would
say was that for example,
let's say you and I are in traffic and
someone cuts us off a normal response.
And certainly one that I often have
is who is that Jerky? You know,
you'd be really pissed off and your
blood pressure would rise and maybe you
would race that guy and uh, you know,
you would, you would think ill of them.
That would be our natural goto thing.
That's a thoughtless,
maybe they're idiotic or
they're inattentive or you
would have all these bad
thoughts about this person who you know
in a road rage kind of way amongst don't
do that with amongst do is is they
train themselves to re narrate.
So when that happens to them,
they say,
maybe that's a man who's taking his
wife to the hospital because she's
delivering the baby. The baby's
being born in the car in front of me.
Isn't that amazing? There's a new life.
I should help that man to get to the Ha.
I mean, and they're doing it
not for the sake of that person,
but for their own wellbeing. You
see, so, so I think it's possible to,
to, to, to read, even
though it's difficult,
is very difficult to exercise
some internal self control.
I think you're mostly saying that there
are no monks on Twitter. Yes, very few.
The Dalai Lama, my things
on Twitter, I think I follow
on. I think I have to check.
Yeah, he's on Facebook, I'm pretty sure.
What else do you think sort of the average
person that's watching this can do to
help order a good society?
Because I think people, you know,
everything's become so political.
Yes.
I think people think that's the only
solution to sort of help make a better,
I think granting charity to your
enemies I think is important.
I think listening to them,
cultivating, listening, you know, um,
that's pretty big of you to
say after everything. Well,
I was listening in the clip
you showed I was listening.
I thought that was so ridiculous.
Like the young woman who said,
I'm not listening to her. I
was really listening. I mean,
I was listening then and before and after.
Um,
I don't agree with what she was saying,
but I heard what she was saying.
I could summarize what she
was saying. Anybody, but,
but what do you do in that case
then? It just sort of, yeah,
we don't have to bring it back to that
specific instance, but in general,
because I think a lot of
people are going through this.
You're being berated by somebody.
They're saying all the worst
things about you and your motives.
They're attacking you as a person.
All of those things now you can listen,
you can absorb, you can ignore,
you can ignore, which is also good.
Ruth Bader Ginsburg says survival in life
is ignoring a lot of the stupidities,
which I also think is good. I think that's
the answer. And what was it we ignore?
And also who was that famous actress that
found this guy in Texas that had said
horrible things to her. And
then, or him I can't remember,
was an actor or an actress and it was
an actress and made it her business to
find out about this guy's life. And he
had lost his health insurance and he,
and then she intervened and raised
money for his healthcare and, and,
and he felt seen and heard and don't
know which one. It's an incredible story.
And um,
and I think that a lot of times people,
and I think anonymity is a real,
it can contributes to bad behavior online.
So I think sort of as Jordan
Peterson says, you know,
man up as it were a woman up and have
the strength of your convictions.
This is what I think, this
is what I'm going to say.
But is there a problem there?
I mean Jordan,
I've done this many times where then
depending on how that hierarchal structure
is operated, you are saying something
that's an politically correct.
Well,
I mean you have to have the strength or
revise your opinions or stick to them or
make good arguments. But
listen, let's don't engage.
Let's say you were a Trump supporter.
You just don't want to lose your job
because you think if you say that
[inaudible] simple as that I'm against
people losing their jobs for their
opinions. Yeah. So, uh, so
you know, so I think that,
I think there is a thing where
I think a little bit of bravery,
a little bit of civil discourse,
a little bit of commitment to
granting charity to our opponents. Um,
a little bit of like for example,
when I would have an argument with
people who are opposed to vaccination,
I think there is no merit to their ideas.
I understand their fears.
I understand that there have been either
some actual cases of vaccine induced
neurological conditions, one in a
hundred thousand one and 500,000 cases,
which is awful.
And I understand that there are a lot
of coincidences where people think that
there's a relationship, but no,
it's just that you have, you know,
you have lot of vaccines
are being administered,
there are a lot of illnesses occurring.
There's going to be an overlap
in those two sets. But,
and I also know the data
on how that's very been a,
how vaccination is like a 20 20th in 2020.
It's actually more than like even a 19th
century triumph. I mean, you know, we've,
we've mastered these diseases.
We humans,
it's astonishing what we've done through
our capacity to teach and learn and
engage in science and so forth. But I
would engage that person. I would try,
I would talk to them.
I would say, you know,
let me talk to you about your beliefs
and because I think that that's the only
way to get them to revise their beliefs.
I think telling them they're
fools doesn't, doesn't help. Um,
a true liberal. I am a liberal. Yes
I am. I am. I am a liberal. Yeah.
But do you think one side is a little,
it's a little bit easier to do that
right now. And does that flip over time?
So for example, right now I find
it much easier to go to consider.
I get invited by conservative glyphs.
Libertarians is no problem,
but let's say conservatives that I
disagreements on abortion and gay marriage
and legalizing marijuana and the
death penalty. And so wait, hold on.
So I'm for legalization of marijuana. Yes.
What is your position on death penalty?
I'm against the death. Me
Too. What were the other that
gay marriage? Yes. Yeah. Uh,
legalizing weed. Yes. Um, so I,
but yes. So I hate to tell you,
I'm guessing that you
only would get invited by
conservative groups to basically
to college as well. I don't know. Um,
I don't know. I don't get that many.
I mean usually my invitations are
scientific. Like I am a scientist.
Like I give talks about my science.
So I have not historically
been very politically right.
So, but what I'm getting,
I really is that at the moment
it seems very obvious to me.
Like I don't know that I could be clear
or anything that's on the center right
there.
There is a,
an ability and a d actually a desire to
discuss ideas would agree to disagree
and that just isn't happening right now.
And I would suspect or argue and I'm
sure he can give me examples where that
during McCarthyism for
example, I think, you know,
it was very difficult to be a
communist for sure. And even, you know,
left where they were so they weren't
inviting Communist. That's right.
Talk to them. And, uh, so I think, um,
I honestly don't know the
answer to that question.
I think there are subgroups on campus
which are still committed to debate the
get the political unions. These guys
love to argue these young people. Um,
I think there are other vocal minorities
on campus that don't want to hear
opinions that they don't agree with and
they think that even the hearing of it,
there's this, there's this very sloppy
conflation of speech with violence,
which I think is ridiculous, um, which
seems to really be ramping up. Yes,
I would agree with that. And you also see
it, for instance, in Pakistan, they will,
they will kill apostates that's
answering speech with violence.
If you actually think that
someone believing in a
different God and expressing
that belief is violence, then then the
country justifies killing that person.
Or in Brunei. Recently they had the
same kind of situation. I think this,
this is, I, I strongly reject
that belief. There's, there's, uh,
we have different words and there's a
totally different meeting between speech
and violence. So, uh, so I don't
know how we got onto that topic, but,
oh, so, so I think that,
I think there are groups
of people on campus who do
conflate speech and violence.
I think that's a problem. Um, but there
are also many groups that are very,
very vigorous political debates.
I think one thing that is different,
so I'm in my fifties when I was
in college in my, in the eighties,
we would stay up late and argue
about politics with our friends,
with our friend's notice. I said, yeah,
my friends and I would argue with
my friends about politics and uh,
and they were my friends. I don't
think that happens very much anymore.
It does in the political unions
and the debates societies.
But in the broader college,
I think if you have a different opinion
about abortion, for example, um,
you really can't express that.
But the weird thing is that it
is happening with conservatives.
Well pleased because they do believe,
I mean I go to these things
and I have these debates with,
he has kids overall and they're better
debaters cause they have more experience.
Yes. Arguing with people
they disagree with. Yes.
They get a better education in some ways
because they have to constantly defend
their opinions. It's a weird
thing like this will happen
to say that. Yes, yes, yes.
I think, well, it'd be if you, this
is the thing why in the martial arts,
for example,
why do we bow to our opponent?
You'll learn more from the people you
disagree with and from the people you
agree with. Right. And Jay is
mill's famous saying, you know,
he who knows only his side of the
case knows little of it. Um, so,
you know,
I think,
I think that's where your ideas
get better when they are tested.
Um, when you argue with
someone you disagree with, um,
and, and, and I think,
and I think cultivating
those kinds of conversations,
disciplining yourself to be able to have
arguments with people you disagree with,
uh, improves your ideas and actually
you should be grateful to that person.
There's more interesting
person in some ways. Um,
now you don't have to be best
friends with that person necessarily,
although you can be.
Um,
but I think it makes you smarter that my
friend is a nice closing statement and
you've lived through it.
I mean,
that's the way you lived through the
forces that so many of us see now as,
as such dangerous forces in designing.
And now that you live through it,
you flourish and you've got another
book out and all of those things. Well,
I would say, I mean, yeah, well, I
would close with saying, you know,
I really believe that, um, that
the arc of our evolution as long,
but it bends towards goodness.
Sounds good to me.
You guys can follow nick on Twitter at
Naa Christakis and we'll have a link to
his book.
Write down below.